[Music]  [Music]  this building is fantastic  oh  it's got life  [Music]  [Music]  it's uh  constructing the way the guys used to do  it I mean friend with all the tools  there before the place  the strengthened foundations underneath  it  [Music]  I suppose it's nice to have that family  connection isn't it  family is everything isn't it a friend  how it must feel perhaps  Jones and Cooper  the first James coming and I mean  obviously Fred was a big part of that  and now we've got JC Builders yes I know  um but you know I hadn't seen his son  carry on and you know obviously very  proud of her how does it feel for you oh  it was good to go back and  come across jobs has been done before  for the by The Firm yeah  so you'll be looking forward to the  opening  you're going to be you'll be here when  we officially open it  [Music]